hello everybody welcome my name is house
make summer kashun welcome to managing
change in an SI p world I'm gonna cover
for you some of the key capabilities
that Google cloud has to offer for SI P
customers to help mitigate the vast
change in these environments and I'm
also going to share with you some
examples of customers who have deployed
their SI p environments on google cloud
and and the results that they're seeing
with these deployments so from the
perspective of challenges for SI p
customers you know times times change
there's you know different times
different year but there's a lot of
consistency in the challenges that these
customers see and the primary one of
course is business continuity for these
mission-critical environments that got
to stay up and running they got to stay
up and running just to support the
business but in parallel businesses are
demanding more certainly there's
economic value that that has to be
driven agility keeping up with the pace
of change keeping up with the needs of
the business and then innovation
certainly you know beyond just the tiny
incremental pieces of innovation
innovation that's that's really going to
to drive improvements so Google cloud
then for SI P customers has so much to
offer I'm gonna hit the highlights here
and then go into some more detail later
in the presentation so you know starting
with robust security and a robust
network that's the underpinning the
ground for for any cloud deployment
added to it with smart infrastructure
things like agility the high
availability the disaster recovery
critical again for for SI P environments
and then you know the capabilities of a
digital business platform a true digital
platform around analytics and machine
learning and artificial intelligence and
then lastly Google clouds commitment to
your to your success this is a not an
easy adventure not an easy project to
move a mission-critical environment like
sa P - to the cloud and we have a lot of
things in place to help you mitigate
risk and help you to get there
so jumping into the network and and
security I just want to start by saying
that you know as a as a baseline a
Google cloud is battle tested from the
get-go for performance for reliability
for security it is already running the
same environment delivering applications
at planet-scale applications that you
know many that you probably use like tea
sweet and maps and YouTube and and
search and Android and others where the
environment is delivering planet-scale
robust secure infrastructure already for
these billions of users that are using
these key Google applications every day
so our you know our security schema or
or environment really is around defense
at depth and at scale and that means
that every element of of the of the
architecture has security baked in
essentially and you know we we built
security through progressive layers we
mostly we build everything ourselves we
buy very very little hardware and the
end service for example where the second
or third largest server manufacturer in
the world and we're the only customer of
our servers our data centers we build
them from the ground up and boards for
example they have you know custom chips
on board that allow them to be
constantly monitoring and looking for
intrusions looking for for possible
changes or problem areas
so every layer of the environment has
security built in another key component
of security is is data encryption and
this is a unique Google cloud feature in
the sense that encryption is done by
default for data and packets in transit
and at rest and there's nothing you need
to do to take advantage of that that's
that's by default so we we don't see
your data we don't if we don't reuse
drives like if a customer were to move
on we would destroy a physical hard
drive we would never reuse a physical
hard drive when it comes to your the
keys for your environment you have
complete control with the keys you keep
your own keys if you
you can hold your keys for you if you
want us to do that so you are in control
of those critical security elements of
your environment from a from a network
perspective there's lots of probably
seen lots of pictures that look just
like this one with you know with the
globe and dots and lines and wires but
the difference with Google clouds
Network is a couple points first of all
it's ours we built it we own it all the
blue lines those are those undersea
cables they're ours
we own them we own the the ships and the
submarines that maintain and manage
those cables that have put those cables
and under the ocean floor so we have
full control over over the network and
that's pretty important because when we
send your data from one region to
another we do not Traverse the public
network so this is both a security
enhancement for you as well as as a
performance enhancement it gives you the
lowest latency possible for your for
your s AP applications and the network
does matter the network matters
tremendously for securities and the top
here there's a typical schema going on
what we call like the hot potato
syndrome where basically one of your
data packets gets tossed around
essentially from from from one network
to another jeonse way to its final
destination and Google Cloud that never
happens essentially again we send your
data from one point to another one
region to another without traversing the
the public networks so big advantages
for s AP customers and like take again
hadr for example where you can host your
high availability systems in different
locations in in a region and ensure
synchronous updates that are that are
sub-millisecond extremely fast low
latency updates for dr for disaster
recovery we can provision dr sites that
are milliseconds away
so we'll come back to h a and dr and
talk more about that as critical as it
is for for s AP customers so moving on
now to smart infrastructure so
augmenting the baseline of security the
baseline
of the of the network with capabilities
like like agility and and more H a and D
our capabilities so the base here for
our for our Google cloud s ap
infrastructure is as a virtualized
environment in like three years back or
so when we decided to host s AP
environments that we would be making an
investment in virtual machines in very
large virtual machines for SA P systems
and that's to to advantages that it
offers customers one is is that you
don't have to get it right in sizing you
know even though you do you run the
tools and the and the scenarios and you
and you you know choose the size of your
initial environments hard to get it
right but you don't have to on Google
Cloud because once you get here you can
quickly adjust and adjust without
penalty and then go forward you can
resize without penalty whether you know
changing times changing things going on
in the market and the environment you
can adjust and and and resize your
environment with what the business
demands or maybe on the weekends or at
night you want to turn stuff off like
your dev or test or non you know
production environments that's available
to you to to save money save money and
in compute instances so global
provisioning in minutes large VMs that
are that are in production and customer
environments and and more and more
investment coming in this area and
future so a key capability thing we are
able to offer in you know in the high
availability space around planned
downtime is live migration and this is
another thing that we're able to offer
because of our VM based environment and
essentially what this is is it's live
migration keeps virtual machine
instances up and running through planned
host system events like a hypervisor
update like a like a patch and you know
the basic hardware or Hardware patch and
this is big for s ap customers when you
know some can't even afford to take a
system down for an hour a month because
that lost downtime is something they
simply cannot cannot afford but the way
it works essentially is you take your
productive live you know your productive
environment and
and move it to a to another VM keep
running certainly no reboots it required
and update the original environment
Patchett update as needed and then and
then you roll back when when the update
is completed so live migrating live
instances without reboots performing
infrastructure updates without
disruption and then you know we to
Google Cloud we take advantage of this
capability to make sure that your
environment is always up-to-date you
know we're not training off downtime and
updates or keeping it updated all the
time and we'll never send you an email
saying the environments going to go down
on Sunday afternoon you need to be
prepared because we don't take down our
environment and you don't need to either
for for doing these types of maintenance
updates alright so moving on you know
more around availability h-a and and dr
so this is so important for us ap
customers to get right again you
architect it rarely you know but but
when when you have to use it it really
needs to be right most of the
environments look like on the left of
this page where you're a che environment
is spread over multiple V pcs virtual
private clouds and that's not great from
it you even in good times it introduces
you know additional points of entry from
a security risk standpoint but then it
you know even concerning more is if you
have a failure and you have to actually
you know failover to a secondary system
it could take a lot of time because you
got to inform the downstream systems
that IP addresses have changed etc so
all your upstream downstream systems
have to be have to be a made aware and
this could take hours in some cases in
the Google cloud setup on the right it's
it's completely different you're a che
can be configured within the same VPC so
that lets say in the event of a failed
system you know you failover to a
secondary which was already up and
running to begin with you fail over to
your secondary and basically it's
synchronously updated and you're back up
and running your failed over within
within seconds without impacting
upstream downstream applications there's
none of that IP remapping
that has to take place you don't have to
send resets there's no DNS table updates
it's business continuity its business
continuity maintained for a permission
critical environment so I want it I'm
going to share with you all here
not just me talking but from one of our
customers cardinal health one of the
largest pharmaceutical distributors in
the United States and they've been
running live si piana on Google cloud
for about nine months or so and I'd like
you to take a listen to their
experiences running sa P on Google cloud
card o health is a global healthcare
service provider we are a company with
over a hundred forty billion dollars of
revenue we have about 50,000 employees
our mission is to be essential to health
care so our customers are relying on us
to make sure that we're protecting the
environment and making sure that we have
a stable platform that they can trust
and rely on it is critical to life or
death for some folks and it's extremely
important to us we you I almost a hard
percent on our ERP based on s ap and all
of our transactions that we execute
right now on medical side goes through s
AP we are actually about 300 servers
here at Cardinal Health on-premise in
our datacenter so very large system very
large scale very difficult to to flex as
we continue to have different business
needs and requirements we had a effort
internally to migrate our workloads out
of our datacenter we were looking for
who is the best provider to work with us
on sa P I think we partnered really
nicely with Google cloud from the very
beginning when we met with Google cloud
you could tell there was a partnership
and helping us through this journey the
opportunities that it presents the
cardinal health the ability to respond
to the business and in a way that we've
never been able to respond to before is
extremely extremely valuable to us and
in a game changer quite honestly we are
a very large volume business so if you
think of a Black Friday we have that
every day at Cardinal Health and Google
cloud has given us the ability to able
to respond to that and scale to shut
down servers when we want to stand them
up is within hours our high availability
and disaster recovery capabilities are
extremely enhanced from a cost savings
perspective we were able to save over
25% quarter-over-quarter and and we're
trending right now to be even save even
more so an
next quarter we continue to partner with
Google cloud on how we can take this
journey to the next level right what's
next it's machine learning artificial
intelligence and how we can deliver
better for our customers and clients
Cardinal Health and Google cloud are
solving for better healthcare experience
for our customers and our patients all
right so moving on to the digital
business platform analytics capabilities
machine learning some of these real
game-changing type of technologies for
your SAT environment they're easier than
you think actually to to get onboard
with and and and deploy so how does how
does Google cloud really innovate for SA
P customers a number of areas that I
want to cover for you first on the left
here is it's actually containerization
with with with kubernetes something so
important for customers for SA P
customers where you know like it or not
for the foreseeable future this is multi
cloud and hybrid cloud and even if
you're able to move your SI p your
primary si P environment to the cloud
you still have to deal with upstream
downstream applications some will be
still on Prem for a while some will be
hybrid some will be in other clouds so
how do you take all of these
applications and elegantly containerize
them and move ahead without fear of the
hybrid nature the multi cloud nature of
the world we're in and the answer for
that is kubernetes for containerization
and then Google Cloud anthos to help you
to build deploy and manage applications
in this in this in this multi cloud
hybrid cloud world
there's also Apogee which is really for
SA P customers takes care of a really
key concern in the area of innovation
where so many customers are concerned
about integration testing this is like
becomes the the worry when they when
they want to explore new new areas of
innovation down there when they go to
test and do integration test they're
worried they're gonna break something
they're gonna break a downstream or
upstream application environment and
with Apogee you don't have to worry
about that because essentially it
provides a way to extract the API layer
so that you're protected your your
downstream applications are our
are protected from from from this kind
of this kind of testing so
infrastructure-as-a-service we've
already covered I'm going to move along
and talk more about analytics and and
and machine learning so in the analytic
space you know smart analytics you know
critical to be using your business data
in a in an informed in a smart way
there's a bunch of certainly si P
operational data of course but most of
the data right is in enterprise data
stores and their disparate right hard to
make good use out of disparate data
stores so this is where bigquery comes
in where you can pull in your Hana data
or your s AP data you can pull in your
enterprise data and then even in some
cases external data sources put them
into this petabyte scale data warehouse
bigquery and leverage our integration
that we have s AP and Hana and Google
Cloud bigquery integration and really
maximize the decision-making power that
you can pull out of this the set of
combined data sources then there's
there's also amazing power with with
machine learning capabilities and so
many really exciting use cases in the SA
P space around machine learning like
automating business processes so money
to automate their use cases around
better understanding your your customer
sales marketing use cases or certainly
supply chain automation as well and
Google Cloud offers the ability to
combine our very powerful AI ml toolset
along with also some key data signals
that come from Google applications
themselves like adding to your
operational data adding examples like
inventory positions or maybe adds data
information or maybe competitive pricing
information all added together and fed
into you know machine learning models
for very powerful insights there's one
example I want to share with you here
which is a customer we have AES who is a
energy company actually and their use
case for Google Cloud machine learning
actually they're leveraging our AI
powered visual inspection capability so
specifically using auto ml for
predicting cracks in windmill turbines
the way it works is they've got a set of
drones that fly around these windmill
mill turbines all you know all day long
during daylight hours and take
photographs of the turbines and send
those photographs in the thousands back
and and those photographs if they were
had to be analyzed by hand or by humans
it would take forever right to be
looking studying them all and looking
for inconsistencies or cracks or issues
but what they've done instead is they've
leveraged Google clouds Auto ml vision
capability trained a model to very
highly accurately detect cracks and
issues with the turbines and and they've
saved fifty seven thousand hours of
manual time ten million dollars in cost
savings by automating this capability
with with Google's visual inspection
capability so you know back to Cardinal
health I wanted to show a second example
the same team at Cardinal Health and how
they have taken their their basic sa P
on Google cloud environment and taken it
one step further with their first ever
machine learning implementation it's a
straightforward implementation but also
a pretty powerful one showing how it can
really save a lot of man-hours and a lot
of money for an for an organization
Cardinal Health has about 50,000
employees across 46 countries our
mission is to be essential to health
care we provide products and services so
that the health care providers can focus
on their patients the industry has
evolved over the last five to ten years
the world is basically moving to
personalization machine learning and
artificial intelligence and we really
just had a great connection culturally
work ethic then also some Co innovation
with Google cloud Cardinal house first
machine learning project went live in
Google cloud every day we have 2,500
emails coming in from the customer
through our buys ap CRM system with
different messages different intentions
so we have to send it to the human
routers a group of 40 people who are
sorting and categorized the email before
we send it to the agents to perform the
tasks that is a very labor-intensive
process we leverage Google cloud native
services and created a null model that
automatically sorted our emails we use
the human categorized emails so we
learned how the categorization can be
done in machine learning and then we
deployed our model into Google cloud the
people that we freed up through the
machine learning they move on to do the
actual work rather than sorting the
emails we are very happy about this
project because it's a milestone for us
we proved that it's achievable and it's
really improved customer service our AI
platform of choice is Google Cloud
[Music]
all right so so that the last piece here
is really about Google cloud being
committed to your success as an SI P
customer and it's not lost on us the the
challenge the concern about you know
moving you're moving s IP which in many
cases the business runs on s ap moving
it and to to the clouds so we have a
number of things that I want to share
with you here that we have to mitigate
the concerns here and and to support you
this critical transition so back about
November of 2019 Google cloud introduced
what we call the cloud acceleration
program it's the first of this type of
program in the industry and it's a
combination of with our partners and you
can see there on the right of the slide
a number of our foundational partners
for the cloud acceleration programs
that's Google cloud with our partners
offering a bunch of really critical
capabilities for you as you move to to
the cloud move s ap Google cloud and
some examples are migration assessments
migration incentives such as you know
Google cloud covering cloud migration
costs for most lift and shift scenarios
you know based on it and a three-year
infrastructure commit we also will cover
you such that there will be no double
infrastructure cost I'll cut over so you
got your productive environment on Prem
possibly you know still running you're
still paying for it you're still funding
but now you've got your pre productive
environment on the cloud while you're
you're working toward cutover we have a
scenario with the cloud acceleration
program that we will eliminate those
double costs for you so you can get to
the cloud without that duplicative cost
scenario also piloting analytics use
cases piloting machine learning can use
cases they're not as hard as you might
think they are actually and with it with
some of our fantastic tech partners here
listed here we can we can help you pilot
and play around with get get your feet
wet and in some of these critical
business innovation areas and then also
you know Google supports safeguarding
your entire environment at the end of
day it's the most important thing that
sa pistes running and supporting the
business and and we have enterprise
support capabilities that complement sa
PS or capabilities to make sure that you
are continuously continuously running so
as I close here I just thought I would
just share you know flash of a subset of
our Google cloud s ap customers that are
trusting their critical s AP environment
to Google cloud I encourage you to you
know let us know how we can help you let
us know how we can help you get started
on this journey check out the resources
there are tons of resources on our s ap
solutions page and thank you so much for
your time thanks for joining today